I have every confidence in it
that there is 1 bright future together
of course there are threats
but if you just use your common sense
and ensures that you are healthy
You have nothing to fear
it is namely 1 psychological warfare
think of your banking for the flu virus
and then have you injected voluntarily
with 1 experimental vaccine
the attention
of the attack that has been committed on your body
distract with 1 so-called war in Ukraine
the next war to scare you even more
until you can no longer watch it
and turns inward
the good and the evil
you send both in the same direction
only the difference is
that the good comes from your free Will
and directs evil to coercion
1 bit the principle of Who does not want to hear
it should feel
same goes for when you get sick
not sometimes they are events in your life
from which you can learn something
what have you done
that you got there
or maybe better said
what HAVE you not done to get there
and the solution
what can you do
to get out
I believe if you take yourverantwoordelijkheid there too
that everything just ends up on its feet again
the next step is
to get you from this hell on earth
to work up to heaven on earth
because it is already there
I will help you in the near future
so you can get started with yourself